Hey, you have to see this.
Fox News host Laura Ingram brought on Dr.
Anthony Foushee to talk to him.
Dr. Foushee, of course, the head infectious
disease official in the United States.
And she tried running these lame talking points
by him like Dr. Fouche.
You know, we never shut down the country for
HIV.
We never shut down the country for SaaS.
Why are we shutting down for a corona virus?
And, of course, Dr. Foushee, a real doctor
who knows about infectious disease.
Unlike Dr. Phil, who is the psychologist or
Dr. Oz or Dr. Drew, although Dr. Drew has
apologized for it, for his disinformation.
I believe Dr. Foushee brutally school schools,
Laura Ingram.
Let's take a look at this.
Douchy on the question of a vaccine.
We don't have a vaccine for SaaS.
I mean, they got close and mice.
We don't have a vaccine for HIV.
And life did go on.
Right.
So the idea that we're definitely going to
have a vaccine, we know did we didn't really
approach much else in the same way as we're
pegging going back to normal with a vaccine
then.
Well, no.
But Laura, this is different.
HIV AIDS is entirely different.
We don't have a vaccine for HIV AIDS, but
we have spectacularly effective treatment,
people who invariably would have died years
ago.
Right now, a leading essentially normal lives.
So it's not just that we have good treatment
for HIV.
That's one part of it.
HIV isn't passed by coughing on someone.
You can't go to work and sneeze and give HIV
to 10 people.
And that's a major difference between HIV
and Corona virus.
Does.
Laura Ingram not know that?
Or is she just playing up the Fox News propaganda?
I'll talk about that a little bit later.
But let's get now to Dr. Foushee.
Addressing the SaaS issue, SaaS is a different
story.
Sors disappeared.
We developed a vaccine.
We're in the Pruit.
We were in the in the process of going through
the various phases.
We showed it was safe.
We showed it induced a good response.
And then SaaS disappeared and we didn't need
to develop a vaccine for PSAs.
So I think it's it's a little bit misleading.
May I compare what we're going through now
with HIV or SaaS?
They're really different.
The question of SaaS disappearing is an interesting
one.
And you have a lot of sort of you could call
them deniers or contrarians saying SaaS disappeared
and so could Corona virus.
The difference is that SaaS seemed to spread
much more slowly.
It took two to three months for there to be
5000 cases in China.
It took a very small amount of time with Corona.
But with this Corona virus, for there to be
5000 cases in China, SaaS seemed to be more
affected by temperature in a way that we don't
yet have a reason to believe this Corona virus
is affected.
And there was much more effective and competent
quarantining and contact tracing early with
stars.
We failed to do that early, which is why we
went from being able to suppress it into these
mitigation tactics that we're now doing, particularly
in the United States.
But Laura keeps saying, couldn't this disappear
just like TSAs?
But we don't know this could disappear.
I mean, Saras did pretty much disappear.
This could as well.
Yeah.
You know you know, anything could Flora.
But I have to time the degree of efficiency
of transmissibility of this is really unprecedented
in anything that I've seen.
It's an extraordinarily efficient virus in
transmitting from one person to another kind
of viruses that don't just disappear.
OK.
And Laura Ingram actually trying to cut off
Dr. Foushee there, but he was able to get
that last thing in which is this Corona virus
is transmitted much more effectively and efficiently
than SaaS as a.
But it's by the data.
Now, as far as Laura Ingram, Laura Ingram's
too educated to believe these non-sense talking
points, right?
I mean, she went to Dartmouth undergrad.
She has a law degree.
She can't actually be this dumb.
She must just be playing up.
Fox is a chosen propaganda, right?
Because it's hard to believe she's that ignorant.
You can't cough at work and give HIV to ten
people.
Why are we even talking about HIV?
HIV is a sexually transmitted disease.
It must be exhausting for not exclusively
to be clear, but originated that way.
It must be exhausting for Foushee to have
to daily do.
I don't know how many interviews he does and
correct the non-sense and the disinformation
to prevent Fox News viewers from behaving
irresponsibly.
Because the more Fox News viewers are exposed
to these types of talking points, we didn't
close down for HIV and Saras just went away.
The more likely they are to engage in behavior
that will spread the infection.
And the sad thing is you can tell Laura Ingram
won't stop these talking points because Foushee
schooled her.
It just doesn't matter.
She listened to what she said.
It's not clear she really heard it.
And she will continue repeating the same talking
points, because that is the tact that Fox
News is taking on this.
It's like, OK, good for Dr. Foushee, but it's
like playing Whac-A-Mole with disinformation.
And sadly, it's not going particularly well,
as evidenced by the protests around the country
over this past weekend.
The David Pakman
Show David Pakman.
Daggone.